il y avait un sentiment quand j'étais enfant
quand j'ai vu Star Wars pour la première fois
que tout était pratique et réel leur
entraîneur une fois convenu de l'océan et semblait
c-3po et r2 il n'y avait aucun doute que c'était une
chose réelle physique tangible vous  le savais
quand vous avez vu le film donc j'ai senti qu'il
était vraiment important que nous rendions VBA aussi
réel que possible bb-8 est si charismatique
un peu fougueux je commence à
me demander si r2d2 est un cousin éloigné
sa conception est si ingénieuse  parce
que j'ai l'impression de l'avoir déjà vu, j'ai l'
impression que c'est familier à l'
univers Star Wars mais ce n'est pas
complètement nouveau c'était un croquis que je
pense que JJ a fait sur une serviette JJ a dit bien d'
accord pourquoi ne pas prendre le suivant
génération à partir de r2, il a été le premier
personnage avec qui j'ai eu de vraies scènes et
j'étais nerveux parce que ce n'est pas un ours humain
pas une sauce lourde très épaisse que la
propriété est qu'ils lui donnent vie Daisy
et John ils le regardent comme une co-star  Je
défie quiconque de ne pas aimer BBA